[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's michael k the yankee broadcaster
the yes network get your copy of
michael's new book
center stage my most fascinating
interviews from a-rod to jay-z now
available online and wherever books
are sold michael joins us now
when's the last time an interview went
bad
you mean an interview with me yeah well
that you conducted
um probably on center stage uh
there's a couple of people that just
didn't want to play very much so
uh um you know you gotta you kind of
coax them i'm sure you've had that as
well
and then you hope that they kind of uh
fall out of it
and uh then it goes well after that but
the books the interviews and the books
those weren't well so the ones that
didn't go well didn't make the book
right right dennis quaid didn't go well
he just he didn't feel like he
wanted to be there but it worked out
i remember interviewing tanya harding
and it didn't go well but it it
spectacularly didn't go well
therefore you're witnessing a car wreck
and i
and that's one of those where i i was
uncomfortable she was uncomfortable
but the fact that like sometimes you let
that go
you just you know that's for the
audience and then they get to it's
almost like
you're eavesdropping and it it was
awful but it
you had it you had to have a visceral
reaction to
it because you're going oh my god is
this actually on the air
and you know so i've had those moments
but where you can't hide
at least you get to tape yours i'm
guessing all of these interviews are
taped
yes they're all taped so they could be
edited and you're right you don't want a
fender bender you want to get t-ball
um the one like you interview a lot of
different people quentin tarantino i
mean
all walks of life there but it feels
like that common thread is they are
sports fans to a certain degree
um but did you find out that there's
certain guys that
maybe like is quentin tarantino a sports
fan
he's a little bit of a sports fan in
order for it to be booked and for the
yes network to be on cable systems it
has to be some kind of
connection to sports so if he watched
the game we'll say okay there's your
connection to sports
but uh quinn tarantino was fascinating
and just to talk to him and get into the
process of
of how he wrote the movies and he writes
the movies in longhand
he doesn't even use a computer that's
kind of stuff i find fascinating so
but they all have a little bit of a
connection to sports for sure
what jumps out if you said to people
wanting to buy
this for father's day the one interview
you must read is which one
my favorite one of the 250 interviews we
did was larry david because i went in
with some trepidation because i was such
a big fan
of seinfeld and of curb your enthusiasm
and i wondered if i was going to get
that larry david and the remarkable
thing is he is that larry david
but he's not as mean you know he'll tell
you exactly what he's thinking but i
think he takes a little bit of the edge
off in real life
even said if i did the things i say in
curb in real life
people would punch me out you always
wonder on curb when you're watching it
why doesn't somebody hit him and he
realizes that but
from that interview alone dan he and i
have become kind of friends which i
think is remarkable
i have such great respect for his talent
and he's just a great guy and he is a
huge
huge sports fan yeah we've had him on a
few times and you're right you're not
quite sure what you're getting
but there's part of you that hopes
you're getting larry david from
curb you're just not sure if that larry
david's going to show up
and then you know ultimately it does in
some form you're like oh my god
that sounds like that would be an
episode of curb your enthusiasm
the book is my most fascinating
interviews from a-rod to jay-z it's
called
center stage we're talking to michael k
the yankee broadcaster
uh recap the week that the yankees have
had so far
well obviously the the red sox series i
think was very illuminating that this is
a team
that that has some issues uh this is a
team that's kept afloat because of
pitching nobody thought that their
pitching was going to be this good
everybody thought that they'd hit over
300 home runs and they would slug their
way
to winning the american league the
hitting has not been there
but the greatest tonic for the new york
yankees over the last 20 years dan
has been the minnesota twins so they
limp into minnesota
and the first two games in minnesota
everything you'd want it to be
yesterday stan hits two home runs uh but
the biggest part of the week
has to be the garrett cole stuff josh
donaldson throwing him under the bus
garrett cole being asked a direct
question about what type of uh
stickum that he uses and he kind of hems
and haws and then yesterday he goes out
and obviously he's working without
anything if he ever has worked with
anything
and he's throwing 100 miles an hour so i
think that was the best way to answer it
back
could yankee pr have rescued garrett
cole in that first press conference
i was thinking about i i hate to place
blame
but i think scott boris is his agent
and garrett's really bright he's one of
the brightest guys i've ever interviewed
and yankee pr maybe they should have sat
together this
question is going to be there this is
the way you should answer and it seemed
like he was surprised
and that surprised me why would you be
surprised at that question
that's the only question that anybody
wants to talk about then he tried to
clean it up a little bit
you know after the game yesterday and
said this isn't really the venue or the
forum for it
and i'm wondering well what is so he's
going to have to answer that question at
some point
and there's so many ways he can answer
it and not throw people under the bus
and not him died himself
but he didn't go that route your
comments
or your thought and i i this is why i
want to have you on
josh donaldson said what he said about
garrett cole and some other pictures
and at least the inference was you were
okay
with garrett cole throwing at josh
donaldson i wanted that was not
that was not the emphasis okay what i
said on my radio show was
god didn't give me talent because he
knows that i'm a vindictive human being
i have a laminated list in my back
pocket
so i said that if i happened to be
garrett cole i didn't advocate for
garrett cole to do it
i would have drilled josh donaldson and
the ribs
okay and then everybody took it and said
that i said that garrett cole should do
it now garrett colts shouldn't do it
because garrett cole is too important to
the yankees he would be suspended
there could be a brawl people could get
hurt but sick michael k
if i was on the mound i would have done
it
let's run down the list of people that
you don't like mike
oh there's so many i don't know if we
want to go there but there's a lot of
people you know
radio and television columnist i i
particularly just
there's a lot of people i really don't
don't particularly have a party at let's
put it that way
um you i there's this um kind of
gray area though if if you put pine tar
on something on the ball or whatever
like that's part of the game
but then if i put something that's a
little better than pine tar on it
then i'm cheating it's unwritten rules
written rules like trying to figure all
of this out
you got pitchers who were dominating it
used to be hitters were dominating now
we want to help out the hitters and it
and i'd liken it to a game of
teeter-totter a taffy pole here
like what does baseball want to want to
be that's what i'm trying to figure out
well that that's the problem dan you
could place the pit up the blame on the
pitchers and the hitters that did the
steroids but
i think major league baseball is a
little bit to blame this is a rule
that's been on the books forever
you can't have a foreign substance on
the ball it has never been enforced
ever now all of a sudden in the middle
of a season you say you're going to
enforce it
and you put one of your biggest stars
garrett cole
unfairly under the spotlight as the
poster child for this
i think it's wrong i really do talked to
out wider yesterday said
95 of people who pitched in major league
history
used something on the ball to actually
get a grip but what's happened now dan
is that really smart people have come up
with the fact if we really get a good
grip we could weaponize it
and increase our spin rate so that makes
it harder to hit and then it becomes a
weapon rather than a tool
and that's where we are right now and
major league baseball says that within a
week
they're going to start cracking down on
it and they're going to check pictures
up to 10 times a game dan
we're talking about piece of game how's
that going to be
and the reason why this becomes a bigger
story espn grabs a hold of it
and you got the yankee star pitcher
you know if this is a picture with if
this is madison baumgardner
nobody cares if it's a twins pitcher
nobody cares it's the yankees
and it's espn has picked up this story
and now
i mean i watched the game last night
just to watch garrett cole
on the mound that's it i didn't care
that you know you know
stanton hit a couple of bombs i wanted
to see his mannerisms like it's
and not that this is why we should watch
a baseball game but i did
search out to watch this game last night
i don't know if baseball benefits
like does any publicity good publicity
work with baseball right now
i mean that's the old adage right and i
i i was off last night i watched every
second of the game because i wanted to
see how he was going to pitch and i
think the only thing that we got out of
yesterday was when he struck out
donaldson
the first two times it was that small
instant where he looked like he stared
at him
like here's your stick em that sort of
deal uh but
in a way if you could bring more eyes to
baseball games that might not have been
there
that's a good thing but i i just get the
feeling dan i don't know if you feel the
same way baseball seems like it shoots
itself in the foot so much it's such a
great game
in its purest form it's such a perfect
game but
then we get moments like this where it
embarrasses itself and it's got to clean
this stuff up it shouldn't
weaponize all these rules and use them
in collective bargaining
um agreements and things like that well
we'll give you the dh if you give us
this
and we'll raise the seams on the
baseball if you give us that
that doesn't work i mean this should all
be behind the scenes where we don't see
the dirty laundry
who's the person you're waiting to
interview
bruce springsteen have you ever
interviewed him
no i have not yeah that would be
interesting this is how close i came to
interviewing bruce springsteen
al leiter was with us in the studio and
al was bragging that he had
springsteen's phone number
and we're live on the air and i said
would you call bruce and al
dialed him up and he was really nervous
because he's thinking
i may not get to keep bruce is going to
change the number
soon as soon as i call and he left a
message
for bruce springsteen during our show
saying uh hey
it's al i'm on the dan patrick show can
you call me back basically
we didn't hear back from springsteen
that's as close as i've come
i met springsteen once in the yankee
clubhouse
and he's walking by and i never do this
because people want their privacy i just
walked up and because
i so loved his music i said i just want
to tell you
that you've written the soundtrack to my
life and he looked at me go
soundtrack to your life yeah
[Laughter]
so that was good enough for me uh fritzy
has
uh bruce springsteen impersonation since
you're a big bruce fan um
i think you might enjoy this this is if
you close your eyes i think it's gonna
sound like uh springsteen or maybe not
okay todd
well all right come on now let's do [ __ ]
put a kiss to bed
all right oh yeah so what do you think
mike wow
can i can i book for you
good luck with the book michael thank
you it's uh great talking to you again
thanks so much dan that's uh michael k
the yankee broadcaster the book
is center stage my most fascinating
interviews from a-rod to jay-z now
available online
wherever books are so